Iranian women have been marching for
their rights and for their dignity
because even during a protest neither is
guaranteed
so this woman is Led away a police
officer grabs her bottom the video of
the sexual assaults has prompted new
outrage
the police have said the incident is
being investigated the video exemplifies
the level of violence that the Islamic
Republic is is willing to use
um showing uh its brutality uh and Brute
Force to get people off the streets and
try and end these sort of unrelenting
protests
Sunday marks a month since Martha amini
who was 22 years old died in custody
after being arrested by Iran's morality
police
her death sparked immediate protests
but their scope widened quickly with
demands all around the country for
greater freedom and even for the
overthrow of the state
in the Northeast they decapitated a
statue of ayatella hamini the former
supreme leader and founder of the
Islamic Republic of Iran
near the border with Pakistan crowds on
Friday called for the death to the
current leader Ayatollah
he had this morning
[Music]
but the tree is being shaken and the
Crackdown is intensifying this video
appears to show security forces massing
in San andaj in the western province of
Kurdistan
activists Say the video shows police
firing weapons in a residential
neighborhood
this the same activists say is what's
left afterwards canisters and cartridges
[Music]
the face of all that they are still
protesting
they are still being hauled away
[Music]
this video emerged today from another
city a woman bundled into a car by a
group of men who brandish weapons at
onlookers she was taken away but the
horrified Cry of the public is not so
easily silenced Tom Cheshire Sky News